serge chalon bonjour bonjour bonjour à
haïti la maudite haïti la désespérée
haïti 116 frappé par tout ce qui existe
comme cataclysme c'est à chalon vous
êtes de l'association usa caraïbes
enfant soleil d'avenir une association
qui fait dans l'humanitaire avec nos
voisins et sakareb a eu du pain sur la
planche ces derniers temps oui oui tout
à fait et d'ailleurs je voudrais définir
ce qui est à caraïbes nous sommes d'une
organisation de solidarité caribéenne
c'est quelque chose de très précis cela
veut dire que au sein même de nos
membres y compris dans notre conseil
d'administration
il ya les personnes qui vivent
effectivement majorité en martinique
mais aussi à sainte lucie en dominique
en république dominicaine et en haïti
ce qui fait que nous pouvons développer
un réseau de solidarité autour de
l'enfant c'est vrai mais un enfant ne
vit pas seul il vit dans une famille
donc autour de l'enfant et de la famille
dans cette région de la kara et c'est ce
qui fait que vous avez imaginé notre
façon de concevoir l'aide humanitaire
dans ce pays parmi les plus pauvres du
monde
oui et j'ai du mal à entendre cette
formulation du pays le plus pauvre du
monde parce que nous avons tous des
richesses comment dirais-je inconnu et
haïti dans la région nous travaillons
qui est celle du sud-est dans la
frontière à la frontière la république
dominicaine c'est une région quand même
150 mille habitants avec quatre grandes
communes je les cite tiote grand gosier
ans à pitre et balance c'est une zone
qui est une zone agricole qui déjà isolé
parce que les dents des montagnes dans
des zones difficilement accessibles et
qui donc se développe mais avec c'est
pratiquement avec ses propres moyens
mais je suis assez frappé de voir
comment il y a dans cette zone là dans
cet arrondissement une organisation de
la vie sociale de la vie communautaire
ça c'est une richesse et ça c'est une
richesse et certaines situations nous
sommes appuyés
alors votre action votre action dead dès
le passage de mathieu qui a semé
désolation en haïti elle a consisté à
quoi non pas de donner pour donner mais
de voir comment faire le système
repartir le plus vite possible
exactement alors il faut savoir que dans
la soirée mais enfin où l'on a su le
moment mais mon insu comme un tueur est
passé nous sommes rentrés en lien avec
cette coopérative qui rassemble
pratiquement toutes les organisations de
cette zone pour vivre avec eux
l'événement comme un os comme dirait
jour minute après minute et c'est ainsi
que l'on peut dire que pratiquement dans
la semaine qui a suivi il était déjà en
capacité de repérer par leur
organisation
les personnes qui avaient le plus subi
dans cette dans cette catastrophe les
besoins les plus urgents tout à fait
tout à fait le 9 octobre on avait déjà
une liste qui était relativement précise
du nombre de familles qui avaient
impacté de maisons détruites et de
choses comme ça et de y ou inondées dans
pratiquement l'ensemble de la zone
et là nous avons défini ensemble une
stratégie c'est à dire qu'elle n'est pas
venue de nous nous l'avons défini
ensemble de cette stratégie passait
mapad ap réalisme humanitaire tout à
fait et ça c'est très important mais
peut-être que notre petite condition
nous permet de faire des choses comme
cela
la plus grande échelle ce serait
peut-être plus de ce célèbre compliqué
alors vous avez fait quoi a été chercher
des vivres dans le pays voisin
république dominicaine nous avons nous
avons d'abord dit qu'il fallait peut
être agir à différents niveaux
le premier c'est effectivement qu'il ya
des personnes qui ont besoin de manger
qui n'avait plus rien qui avait
complètement perdu la totalité de l'aide
de leurs possibilités et à ce moment là
nous avons décidé de faire des achats de
vivre qu'il que nous avons défini
ensemble du riz des pois de l'huile des
choses de base que nous avons été acheté
à côté en république dominicaine
pourquoi parce que depuis port au prince
ça devenait il était impossible il ya
des alarmes a vu les immenses la
révision c'est donc nous avons décidé de
l'acheter à port au prince et et tenez
vous bien c'est quelqu'un de la de saint
domingue daid de débats ts qui a qui a
structuré organisé tout l'achat dans
cette région des batteuses c'est là où
vivent les haïtiens république
dominicaine et donc c'est un de nos
correspondants labaki a organisé cela
nous allons acheter pratiquement 7000
euros de vivre à saint domingue examen
alors oui c'est suffisant mille euros
c'est sans sac de riz c'est 30 35 sacs
de de poids c'est une cinquantaine de
gallon 1 gallon c'est 4 litres d'huile
et c'était de la première urgence
c'était pour amorcer ses actions alors
deuxième action vous avez identifié des
familles bien précises avec un réseau un
réseau d'associations sur place encore
invitant les femmes un réseau de femmes
c'est à dire que c'est pour cela que je
veux dire que eighties n'est pas dans
une situation désespérée elle est
désespérée dans l'eau travers des images
mais pas au travers de l'armée au
travers de son énergie
en fait il ya une association de femmes
qui est qui s'organise sur l'ensemble du
territoire de cette zone là et qui a
repéré donc je pense qui mieux qu'une
femme de repères ce des besoins d'une
famille je ne sais mais en tout cas
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement fort
et qui a permis qui nous a demandé de
donner à ces personnes les capacités de
réagir de résilience de rebondir parce
que chacun a des priorités différentes
hanouna vous n'avez pas les mêmes
priorités comme moi même après une
catastrophe et nous avons décidé de
donner de l'argent
c'est à dire de 2 bd des gens numéraire
et nous avons donné 2000 euros 2000
euros pensée 2000 bourde à chaque
famille qui représente à peu près la
moitié d'un salaire l'orientation en
euros 30 euros à chaque famille pour
qu'elle puisse à partir de là
reconstruire des choses qui leur
semblent être les plus urgentes et là
vous avez eu des témoignages assez
extraordinaire réelle portée par ce
soutien où les gens sont acteurs même de
leur comment dirais-je de deux de leurs
façons de réagir et de se remettre en
selle zone agricole avait également aidé
ces agriculteurs pour qu'ils puissent
tout de suite renous rire leur
population dans les deux trois mois vous
avez tout à fait parce que lorsque vous
donner du riz et des pois tous les jours
vous mettez des gens en attente et vous
leur de vous les mettez dans une
situation de la naksa du convoi
humanitaire
ça fait des attaques de convois
humanitaires et surtout ça fait que dans
deux trois mois vous avez toujours des
gens qui sont en attente de quelque
chose parce qu ils rien n'a été
construit autour et don royal t'aidera
avec voilà exactement avec dix
coopératives agricoles
nous avons considéré que le meilleur
moyen d aider c'était d'acheter des
semences et du fumier pour que le
redémarre ses jardins qui ont été
complètement laminé et ça correspond à
200 familles qui ont été accompagnés
d'un point de vue agricole pape au pot
pour que dans deux à trois mois ils se
retrouvent avec de quoi fonctionner
alors et la caraïbe a recueilli à peu
près peu moins de 25 mille euros depuis
le passage de matthews avait déjà
quasiment toutes utilisées 19000 20000
euros
cette façon de faire cette pratique
cette méthode cette philosophie pour
qu'on peut pas l'étendre à l'ensemble du
pays alors c'est déjà entendu les
critiques qui tout un feu sur elle tout
à fait et je pense que ces critiques
ignore d'une part l'organisation et
terme du pays
si on sait qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent
qui est versée et que l'argent allait
elle est versée peut-être niveau de
structures qui ne sont pas en
communication directe avec sa relation
sur le découvre pas certain on le sait
la précarité tout à fait et la deuxième
chose c'est que on a on veut aussi
montrer des images d'un pays si vous
voulez qui est qui est complètement à
l'abandon mais qui dans en état si vous
voulez de demandes permanentes
or ce n'est pas le cas ça fait le buzz
de montrer ces images de tout ce que je
veux dire pour éclairer mon propos c'est
que après par exemple cette grande
catastrophe de 2010 qu'à plus de 80% des
personnes qui ont été sauvées après ce
tremblement de terre
on était par les haïtiens eux mêmes et
pourtant vous l'avez vu que sur les
images que ces quelques pourcents qui
ont été sauvés par des fils de
l'endurance et de la solidarité d'abord
à port au prince étaient les gamins du
quartier qu'ils allaient déblayer les
absolument et ça se passe et nous le
savons aussi parce que nous vivons aussi
des catastrophes nous vivons aussi la
divination de toute cette polémique
les propos de ban ki moon secrétaire
général des nations unies qui dit donner
plus et puis le président provisoire en
haïti qui dit ne voulons pas subir cette
urgence humanitaire
ce débat là aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
une bonne chose pour haïti pour la suite
oui parce que je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à donner autrement et c'est en
ça que nous de ce que nous avons à aider
ce pays dans cette solidarité dont je
parle à savoir qu' il y a aussi des
hommes des femmes avec leur dignité et
avec aussi des projets avec aussi une
organisation
même si elle est faible même si elle
nécessite des moyens même si elle est
écrasée par des années de de dérives
politiques il y a quand même ces
personnes comme vous et moi qui sont en
capacité de réagir en capacité de
résilience et c'est vers eux qu'il faut
aller directement en évidence la
richesse des styles et c'est ça la
richesse d'haïti parce qu'elle est aussi
cette richesse de tous tu m'aimes qui
fait que nous sommes devant des hommes
et des femmes qui ont aussi tout comme
nous cette capacité aussi de réagir
cette capacité de résidence et c'est
vers eux qu'il faut aller et nous on ne
peut pas deux jours de com en un jour
toucher ces personnes il faut construire
cette solidarité pour que lors d'une
prochaine
catastrophe parce qu'il y en aura
d'autres de ce type on touche des gens
qui sont en capacité de la faire
fonctionner de cette solidarité dernière
question d'autres associations viennent
vous voir pour votre méthode
il a en pas tellement pas tellement car
je pense que nous sommes restés sur des
schémas classiques qui disent qu'il faut
aller courir au secours des gens et leur
faire des distributions
je pense que benkemoun dans l'ain
d'ailleurs de ces de c2c dans l'une de
ses interviews a dit il nous faut aussi
aider les personnes pour que dans deux
trois mois ils sont en capacité de
résidence eux mêmes et ça c'est très
important
en tout cas je veux rappeler que ce
soutien continue et que vous pouvez
toujours continuer à les aider à
caraïbes
de façon concrète à travers les donne au
travers d'eux
merci serge chalon d'avoir avec ton
rappelle que vous êtes membre fondateur
fondateur d'ee à caraïbes enfant soleil
d'aveux dire merci